[Music]
on october 19
2017 at the haleakala observatory in
hawaii
human beings detected the first ever
visitor from interstellar space
an object from outside our own solar
system
a pair of harvard scientists say a
massive fast-moving visitor to our solar
system may have been a probe sent by an
advanced alien civilization
it's an alien spacecraft some sort of
alien technology perhaps exploring the
cosmos
it's called omuamua which roughly
translates as messenger from the past
reaching out to us in hawaiian
everything in our solar system is on a
closed loop you know some orbits are
nearly circular
some are elongated this one was an
open-ended orbit
which means it's coming from outside the
solar system
then something even more strange
happened
upon leaving the inner solar system
astronomers reported an unexpected
acceleration
only adding to the hypothesis that omumu
was some sort of alien creation
it would be exciting to think this is an
alien spacecraft
uh you know it's one of the burning
questions on many
minds is are we alone but you have to be
responsible about it and if there is a
perfectly
common explanation you shouldn't go to
the exotic explanation
after observing the object most
astronomers agreed that it's probably a
comet
like 2i borosov the other interstellar
objects seen a year later
but we may never know for sure
things that come in on these type of
very elongated orbits
move really fast when they're close to
the sun
and then there's much slower as they
move out of the solar system
so when you looked at the brightness of
this object it was going to only be easy
to observe for about a week
[Music]
in that short window of time with just a
pinpoint of light
scientists were able to make guesses on
the object's shape
its size how fast it was spinning and
its color
which is thought to be reddish but there
are a lot of questions about umuah
and space that will remain unanswered
unless we're able to act more quickly
right now many of the teams are saying
we need the capability to have reactive
missions fast missions that can respond
to a discovery
because right now the the missions the
way nasa works with the small missions
is you put in a proposal and it takes
many years to get that approved
and then it might be a decade between
proposal and actually launching a
mission
and obviously for omuamua that would
have been pointless
so we would like to have missions that
are maybe
ready to go built and in orbit waiting
for new discovery
or something that could be launched
immediately
that's why teams of scientists are
planning missions to wait for objects in
space
and spring into action as soon as
something interesting is detected
it may be humanity's only chance to see
an object from another
solar system up close
the space between solar systems is huge
unless warp drives become a reality
traveling from one to another anytime
soon is
probably not possible well i mean i'm
i'm a star trek fan and according to
star trek in 2063 i think
safran cochrane in invents the warp
drive
zefram cochrane
of alpha century the discoverer of the
space war
that's right captain so if that happens
definitely if not i think it's quite
difficult to
reach anything within my lifetime
currently the only way that we have to
see some of the
material from these other star systems
is stuff
that is in interstellar space that gets
to us
although we've never gone near an
interstellar object we've learned a lot
from approaching objects from within our
solar system
in 2014 the european space agency's
rosetta probe
rendezvoused with comet 67p
rosetta is the first mission that ever
delivered
a lander to the surface of the comet
this
has never been done before it is the
first mission that went into orbit
around the comet and it accompanied it
for two years and a bit from 2014 to
2016.
and from this mission the european space
agency made a lot of interesting
observations
i think this shape was one of the major
surprises that we had at the beginning
no one really expected that
another really big discovery i think was
that
the water that came off comet 67p
is not that kind of water that we have
on earth
and if it's not the same you know that
they're probably not from the same
source so i think this was quite
unexpected because people really thought
this comet could be a real possibility
to bring water to earth
scientists are still looking at the data
from the rosetta mission and making
exciting new discoveries about 67p
and those discoveries in turn give us
hints about the early days of our solar
system
i think comets are very interesting um
because they can actually tell us where
we come from
the comets are always thought as kind of
leftovers from the solar system
formation
[Music]
and if we explore comets we can
understand how the solar system formed
how earth
formed and basically how humans in the
end
came to be because without earth that we
wouldn't be here
while the rosetta mission was a success
comet 67p orbits the sun every seven
years and is affected by the heat
losing gases and changing its
composition with each orbit
scientists at esa recognize the need to
study a comet with a pristine surface
one that's never been near the sun and
that's largely unchanged since the
formation of our solar system
this is known as a new comet
they were talking about this problem of
pristine
surface versus change surface and they
said well
you know what we should do we should try
and get to one of those new comets
and so the comet interceptor idea was
born
this is very different from previous
missions that we've done
where we've always gone to comets that
go round and round in the solar system
and the reason why we go to these is
that we know where they are
we can observe them and then get their
position very accurately
but comet interceptor doesn't want to do
that comet interceptor wants to go
to a very new comet and observe it
with three different little spacecraft
um
one mother spacecraft as we call it and
two
sub-spacecraft and we want to
basically observe everything we can
we'll take pictures
of the comet's nucleus which is the
little thing in the middle
we'll take pictures of the gases around
it the dust that comes off of it
the environment
interstellar objects are not common
interceptors primary target
since we've only ever detected two we
don't know when or if we'll detect
another one
this mission is mainly going after
unknown new comets
from beyond neptune in the oort cloud
this is the spherical outer part of the
solar system
and is believed to contain trillions of
comets
the majority have never entered the
inner solar system
but every once in a while one of these
icy bodies gets a gravitational bump
from another object
flinging into the inner solar system and
comet interceptor hopes to be ready for
the next one
and there is another very interesting
target family
let's say which is interstellar objects
so
if there is an interstellar object um
like or borisov that's obviously where
we will be going
because that's by far the most
interesting
thing that we can explore and comet
interceptor is the only mission that has
the capability
to explore such an interstellar object
but to catch up to a new comment from
our solar system
or an interstellar object they needed to
come up with a way to deal with the
short lead time
something that's never been done before
the problem is that these dynamically
new comets are usually detected
just a couple months before they get
close to earth
and a couple months as everyone involved
in
any space mission knows is not enough to
build a spacecraft
and go somewhere with it
so we're actually more looking at a time
frame of
five years for the mission where we have
five years of waiting time and we can
choose whenever
we detect a suitable comet and we think
that
the chance of detecting a suitable
dynamically new comet
that we can reach is over 90 percent
over these five years to be able to wait
for a comet out in space for up to five
years
they'll send a small probe to the
earth's sun lagrange point
a place where the gravitational pull
from both bodies cancel each other out
creating a stable orbit
and when comet interceptor gets there
it'll just
wait for five years and once we detect
the comet
we'll be setting off towards
a rendezvous point and this will be done
with chemical propulsion
data gathered by the interceptor could
be compared to other comet missions
so scientists will be able to predict
the effects of the sun on comets
giving them clues as to what the
formation of our solar system was like
and in turn teach us how earth came to
be
it is a very ambitious mission that's i
think why it's so exciting
i mean if you just do things that are
easy it's a bit boring
so this mission is very difficult to
pull off
and i think that the team here at esa
has done a very good job in kind of
reminding everyone of the constraints of
the mission
while still getting the best science out
of it that we can expect at the end
although not as far along as is comet
interceptor which is set to launch in
2029
there is a team at mit in its initial
planning stages
designing a mission specifically
targeting interstellar objects
so um we see interstellar objects as the
new frontier
in uh planetary uh sciences
and now that we detected them it really
opens up the door of like oh what new
things can we discover
and how does these new discoveries frame
our thinking about the formation of this
star system and other star systems
so it's really science in a nutshell
their proposal is called dynamic orbital
slingshot for rendezvous with
interstellar objects
much like the comet interceptor it will
wait in space
and spring into action at the right time
so the unique part about our concept
is that using the solar cell our payload
remains
stationary we can completely cancel out
this force of gravity
of course the materials that are
required for this are exotic
some of the materials are currently
being developed at academic labs
so we think it's within the realm of
possibility for future mission to do
something like this
we can lay in wait watch our
local space for any interstellar objects
that might be entering that space
and then spring to action and uh get a
close-up view of that interstellar
object
once an object is detected it would be
allowed to leverage the gravitational
force of the sun
in a free-fall trajectory towards the
detected object
matching its path
the team receive phase one funding from
nasa which gives them nine months to
come up with a solid plan
before applying for the next phases
we're optimistic about phase two and we
hope to eventually get to a phase three
and if we're able to get there then this
technology becomes closer to becoming
reality
and both of these missions are coming at
a good time
telescopes that are coming online in the
next few years will be able to detect
more pristine comets
and interstellar objects than ever
before
large synoptic survey telescope the
reuben observatory
is being built in chile and that's going
to be much bigger
and scientists are predicting we might
start to see one of these
each year once that is built because it
goes much fainter
why is it important to study objects
like this
well i think omuamua and other
interstellar objects
are really important because they are
the
likely leftovers of building planets in
another solar system
and right now we don't have the
sensitivity or resolution
to really watch that process unfold
and you know for example are all solar
systems chemically the same is at the
same
physical processes that build planets
because this is important
for the question of are we alone and so
some of the ways to answer those
questions require
detailed chemical compositional makeup
which you can't do remotely
i think we should be interested in
interstellar object because it really
tells us something about our own history
whether or not our star system is unique
or are is our star system similar to
other star systems
and if we find out maybe some
compositions of the materials
around other star systems it could
inform us what's out there
if we can explore an interstellar object
we can
explore by proxy another solar system
and that's something really exciting
because we know there's
so many other solar systems with
exoplanets
and with maybe even exoplanets that are
kind of like earth
and understanding those systems better i
think is really interesting
you